hallo ich bin da würd ich bin 18 jahre
alt kommen aus der nähe von köln habe
dieses jahr mein abitur gemacht und wer
jetzt eigentlich ein halbes jahr in
asien musste die reise aber leider
kurzfristig absagen
ich habe seit vier jahren mit premiere
geschnitten und bin jetzt seit vier
monaten auf eine karte gestiegen genauso
wie es von canon auf sonnige switch bin
und neben meiner leidenschaft für film-
foto- und allgemein technik bin ich sehr
sportbegeistert und besonders skier und
snowboard fahren hat mich gehetzt reicht
das schon mache seit ich denken kann
jetzt viel spaß mit den letzten paar
sekunden und den letzten aufnahmen
[Musik]